Ciao ragazzi Sono le 7 Il Mattino
praticamente alle 6:30 è arrivato Sto
allarme che diceva di evacuare tutti
quanti e di far andare prima le donne e
i bambini gli anziani Quindi mi sono
svegliato in panicatissimo perché non
avevo messo sveglia e mi sono rimesso a
dormire Cioè poteva arrivare di tutto mi
si meteoriti poi hanno mandato un altro
messaggio han detto che quello gli è
partito per sbaglio Si vede che uno ha
cliccato sulla tastiera per sbaglio
Vabbè niente è successo questa cosa l'ho
condividerla con voi sono vivo per
miracolo ma se fosse stata una cosa
seria sarei morto nel sonno Vabbè Ehm
Boh video ragazzi buon video e quindi
ragazzi per pranzo proviamo il piatto
tipico coreano i gnocchi Scusi mi danno
un piatto di gnocchi Thank you sempre
sognato di camminare per Seul con un bel
piattozzo di gnocchi bone Oh che sono
dei Quartieri principali di Tokyo dove
c'è Eh sì Seul Dove ci sta le bangaranha
che vendono le cose belle e io ho
comprato gli gnocchi ma nostra immensa
fortuna è che abbiamo l'albergo qua
siamo usciti e ci stavano gli gnocchi
Ecco questo è un Market
coreano che non è proprio l'Esselunga
diamo un attimo cosa su Cos'è sta roba
qua vendono tutta roba speziata questa
cosa qua è una caratteristica credo
della Corea in generale a livello di
drink sono sempre molto sobri Eh boh
Oddio che figata
lo yogurt di genshin impact base entrare
in un Market giapponese mi fa strano qui
proprio un'altra roba un altro pianeta
no
c'è un Charmander con quattro denti c'è
un po' questo evolver di Wish
Ma roba e io non so questo super market
normale ragazzi va bene Mi chiedo se
anche a casa delle nonne coreane ci
siano ago e filo qua dentro Ovviamente
non ci sono mai stati i biscotti dice il
contrario sta mentendo Oh finalmente
Forza Napoli Ragazzi vi faccio vedere il
lavoro number one del mondo
veramente degli Spiderman Questo è
proprio il multiverso Cioè ci stanno
tutti e quattro ma neanche se mi dessero
un jet privato fare questa cosa Però
parliamone parliamone e siamo arrivati
davanti a una chiesa coreana che è
esattamente come quella italiana non
entro perché rispetto c'è gente che sta
pregando Comunque sia è identico non
avrei mai detto C'è anche Suor John
goong panorama de Cristo nel primo senza
la parola molto figo tra l'altro c'è un
sole della madonna e io mi sto
squagliato Allora non mi è mai successo
Ok in una città di avere questo problema
non so quando registrare perché tutto
bello Quindi o faccio un video della
durata di 6 ore dove riprendo anche il
cosino oppure mi metto l'anima in pace
non registro tutto perché ragazzi
qualsiasi posto a Seul ma anche il
cestino l'immondizia e tra parentesi ce
n'è uno ogni 6 km è bello quindi non so
cosa dire cos'è stavo camminando non
sapevo di sto posto che cazzo è perché
esiste questa cosa siamo in Zelda io non
ho parole Ragazzi Adesso andrò lì
a parte sta cacata Ragazzi comunque c'è
tutta la riva e c'è tutta la camminata
al giorno cadranno so quante persone
figo molto figo adesso ci facciamo sta
camminata la roba che dicevo l'altra
volta ovvero il quartiere
tradizionale chiamiamolo così perché non
saprei come chiamarlo visto che non so
una sega è questo Cioè tu vai in giro ci
sono i negozietti carini molto Chill
soprattutto ragazzi non c'è più una
nuvola è solo una quella e ci sono 2
milioni di gradi cioè New Balance e la
cosa più interessante Si può fare il
passaporto la carta d'identità Ecco qua
ad esempio qua ad esempio qua ad esempio
[Musica]
Comunque ragazzi Questa è una via
incredibile ragazzi se c'è una cosa che
ho imparato a Seul ma comunque in
generale nella vita e che se avete un
figlio piccolo non Lasciatelo con i
pastelli in mano davanti alla vostra
macchina comunque Ragazzi c'è da dire
che Seul è una città pazzesca perché ti
dà raga pazzesco ho trovato gaulenti a
Seul come come Palazzolo Unicredit c'è
anche Sam il mio cane Sì un po' più
curato oggi ragazzi voglio morire
stiamo per mangiare una pizza a dal 2011
ancora morto
Vabbè ragazzi dai uno vuole sempre
partire il benvenuto però pomodoro Cutro
ma neanche che però no però mi sembra un
Good Look ovviamente Ragazzi sto
scherzando Vorrei solo morire
velocemente Beh ho visto di peggio ho
visto anche molto di meglio eh proviamo
ragazzi
i draghi Massimo Questo è il giapponese
sa di cartone
[Musica]
quando c'è proprio due ragazzi siamo al
lotte Wood nel caso vi stesse chiedendo
Cosa c'è all'interno dell'occhio
ragazzi eh Minchia pazzesco Ti sei
proprio fortissimi io non so stare
neanche in piedi Dio santo c'è una
mongolfiera che si muove Mi sembra
eccessivo raga due mongolfiere c'è pure
la metro cioè raga Vabbè stavo
constatando ragazzi Io non sono mai
stato a Dubai nel bosco questo e
attualmente l'edificio più grosso che io
abbia mai visto io non so che possa
esserci una roba più grossa di questa
tranne il mio Ca Ok raga l'entrata di
questa magica
controllato tra l'altro sono 555 m di
altezza ed è anche molto chic Ah ma
questi sono impazzito
Guinness World Record Beh certo che ha
vinto le Guinness non mi servivano Nek
Sta di qua vicino a Monsters & Company
Eccoci qua allora un ticket costa
39.000 partiranno anche un drink c'è
scritto lì giuro oppure vuol dire Non
sporgersi troppo perché sono morto ok
anche l'entrata umile Vediamo se
funziona il ticket che ho appena preso
dal 117 A 123 Eh facciamo le scale
ragazzi
ok Beh stiamo andando nello spazio chi
soffre di vertigini ehm spenga il video
No scherzo
ma è follia Porca adesso spunta
una macchina dal muro e ci invento
lo sapevo che funziona sta cosa lo
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo Adesso c'è il
Gabibbo che faccio Posso vedere anche
casa mia l'abbiate grasso Eh no vabbè
sto male giuro su Dio che sembra un
modellino sembra di vedere un modellino
Madonna cioè il mio Massimo è stato
L'Empire mi sa L'Empire di New York
questo se lo mangia pazzesco Sì cos'è
cos'è sto posto cos'è Comunque il mio
albergo più o meno sta in quelle zone lì
Questa è tutta la parte dal di là del
fiume la cosa che mi fa impressione
tutti questi edifici che vedete stanno
tutti un giga numero sulla facciata del
palazzo che indica appunto il numero di
Palazzo è E questa cosa è assurda si
vede più o meno da qua Ah la mia parte
preferita ecco qua ecco
Mannaggia il cavolo ragazzi è
terrificante No ragazzi è terribile ok
ok ok arrivederci là rispetto a quella
di Tokyo è una cosa incredibile Madonna
Dai pazzesca sta roba tra l'altro quanti
atterraggi per elicotteri ci sono sui
palazzi di Seul chiaro perché se abiti
lì invece di trovare parcheggio
parcheggio sul tetto ci può stare
Vediamo se funziona 'sti cosi Ah beh
però è figo dai Minchia puoi zoomare
qualsiasi cosa Aspetta che vedo nella
casa della signora cosa fai se ti entra
un Favij in casa Benvenuti a un'altra
giornata di Facciamoci i cazzi degli
altri Ah questa ha parcheggiato male
allo zoom per 36
allora per essere a vedere si vede
Abbiategrasso Eccolo qua Qualcuno ha
detto Justice No non l'ha detto nessuno
perché qua voglio vedere come ci arrivo
a casa tua c'è traffico in tangenziale
Tu esci guardi qua e poi capisci se
prender la macchina
Io sono mega sorpresa e poi c'è lo zoom
del suo telefono che va più del mio di
questo qua è pazzesca 50 più ben speso
della mia vita peccato perché se lo
mettevano di qua il binocolo potevo
guardare la partita gratis è stato
fighissimo ragazzi veramente fighissimo
Adesso però cambiamo perché noi che
possiamo stare con tutto il giorno ecco
le scale va bene Mamma mia che occhiaie
Oh ragazzi Secondo me stanotte non ho
dormito tanto comunque sia
mi piace ho riconosciuto la canzone Mi
stavo proprio giusto parlando di questo
non ci credo hanno fatto la statua siamo
nel quartiere di Gunner Gangnam Style
ragazzi non so se avete presente
Immagino di sì dieci anni fa nasceva
questa leggenda musicale La canzone
credo parli proprio di questo visto che
si chiama Gangnam Style è sempre qua nel
quartiere di gunnam ne hai parlato in
questo posto in particolare perché c'è
questo centro commerciale che si chiama
Coez praticamente all'interno ha una
giga libreria forse giustamente non si
potrà parlare ad alta voce perché c'è un
sacco di gente che legge molto figo
l'avevo vista dalle foto e dal vivo e
ancora più figo Mamma mia ragazzi Ecco
una cosa che non ho capito è che se per
caso a me dovesse servire quel libro lì
Qua rosso come cazzo lo prendi per darvi
un'idea Secondo me qua ci saranno
[Musica]
sette libri penso che se per caso vado a
prendere un libro lo sposto nello
scaffale sbagliato finisco in galera se
posso dire la mia secondo me questo
posto dal suo Massimo d'inverno perché
d'inverno tu immaginati che tutto il
freddolito Entri qua Prendi un bel
Coffee da Starbucks e ti sorseggi il tuo
caffeino mentre leggi un libro qua
secondo me Mood che poi tra l'altro
questo sarà addobbato natalizio non è
questo Mood da provare ragazzi
la cosa più bella ragazzi di Seul è
trovare posti senza fare Plan Cioè nel
senso Uno va in giro cammina e trova
queste cose cioè questo io ragazzi non
so cosa sia fico È incredibile Comunque
ragazzi sono gli ultimi giorni qua seoul
e se posso essere sincero È una delle
più belle città che io abbia mai visto
tutto questo
cose qua sono in mezzo alla metropoli
che rende il tutto più suggestivo
veramente figo bella per seoul posso
prenderne uno lo porta a casa video in
carcere e comunque Ragazzi visto che
siamo a Seul e fa un caldo torrido Tra
l'altro perché effettivamente in questi
giorni i primi ha piovuto ma adesso fa
un caldo Torri la cosa principale che ti
dico sempre a tutti quanti è di rimanere
idratati ma questa volta lo faccio in
maniera stilosa vi faccio vedere dentro
la mia sacca magica ho portato un
qualcosa che potrebbe interessarvi ed è
Ehi rap Ehi rap raga permette di
idratarsi casa sempre importante ma
facendoli in maniera più stilosa perché
voi avete la vostra borraccia abbiamo
questi magici Pod io ho portato l'intero
sacchetto per farvi vedere il
funzionamento questo qua in particolare
è alla
pesca ghiacciato il gusto è quello della
pesca ghiacciato ovviamente ce ne sono
tantissimi come me Le cannella cioè sono
un miliardo io potete scegliere il
vostro gusto preferito ma il mio in
assoluto è Ice Stitch Quindi se volete
un consiglio lo apriamo così lo
estraiamo da qua e dopodiché ragazzi lo
applichiamo nel verso corretto alla
nostra borraccia e quando noi facciamo
questa cosa qua noi possiamo utilizzare
la magia perché la magia avviene quando
noi alziamo il nostro Pod L'acqua ha un
gusto magico L'importante ragazzi
bisogna tenerla assolutamente dritta La
borraccia perché il funzionamento È
corretto in questo modo testiamo
questa cosa incredibile grazie alla
retro olfattività
poi con l'olfatto sentite il sapore ok
Quindi non è l'acqua e acqua Quindi voi
solo con l'olfatto sentite il gusto
dell'acqua in qualche modo incredibile
Questa cosa è incredibile Quindi ragazzi
Provate un paio di gusti e fatemi sapere
perché secondo me merita un sacco
rimanete idratati che è importante
ultima cosa ma non per importanza i pod
di rap sono più sostenibili delle
lattine gassate normali di 25 volte fino
anche a 50 volte Addirittura quindi ecco
sostenibilità sapore col fatto e
idratazione ragazzi mega importante
soprattutto qua se vuoi perché fa un
caldo bestia è Direi che possiamo
tornare al nostro viaggio ragazzi Let's
go
e per la serie spingiamoci sempre oltre
Stiamo andando su quella magica Torre
che sembra un po' la torretta a Rozzano
perché è Lombardo mi capisce è per
raggiungerla bisogna usare la funicolare
[Musica]
ragazzi si possa aggiungere un commento
mi sto cacando sotto però se non
facciamolo vedere dopo aver fatto bungee
jumping paracadutismo magari siamo quasi
arrivati alla torre raga e sta tipo lì
non si vede ma esattamente che cacchio
succede qua sono un miliardo di
Lucchetti e ce sta mega papera Ma perché
Perché Annuccia non capisco le cose non
ci sarà una cosa in italiano scritta
lasciate un iPhone Siccome la maggior
parte sono finti Cioè l'hanno messo qua
della serie Vabbè Creiamo un punto di
attrazione nostalgico per la gente Beh
perché non è possibile Non ho mai visto
una cosa del genere neanche i ponti a
Roma cioè da Verona è veramente assurdo
comunque c'è una vista cioè si vede
meglio che qua che è alla Tower quella
di Cristo per te oggi c'è un sole che
spacca le pietre C'è una vista così non
si possono usare i droni Tra l'altro
Meno male perché stavo per mandare
giusto le riprese col drone a Giampiero
c'è tutta la parte centrale
sostanzialmente di Seul il mio tele tipo
uno di questi e qua c'è la giga Torre si
chiama Torre
[Musica]
e quindi ragazzi siamo a due ore di
cammino attenzione potremmo essere
arrivati a una svolta incredibile
finiscono
16 km Lucchetti per arrivare alla torre
che però Rozzano ne sa se fossi in Zelda
perché ci sto giocando tutti i giorni Mi
butterei da qua col parapendio sai
quanto ci mette arrivare all'albergo con
quello 5 minuti neanche ho già detto e
lo ripeto la scelta di venire a Seul 5
giorni è stata forse una delle scelte
migliori della mia vita di sicuro non
quella di fare informatica al tecnico
quella non è stata una gran scelta se
venite a Seul andate a visitare la Seo
Tower Fortunatamente anche abbastanza
vicino al mio albergo Quindi mandata
pure di culo Io ormai ho finito le
parole ragazzi scrivo questa cosa molto
simpatica qua vedete che ci sono questi
portafortuna Insomma dediche è un
qualcosa di spirituale voi acquistate
queste palline vi dovrebbe dare un
suggerimento stile di vita come potete
vedere ci sono dei degli animali
disegnati questo perché il segno
zodiacale asiatico è diverso da quello
di noi occidentale ad esempio il mio
segno zodiacale ce l'ho anche qua è
quello del cinghiale abbiamo i nostri
mille Won che corrispondono circa 60
centesimi inseriamo qua all'interno e mi
dà un gettone questo gettone noi lo
mettiamo nel nostro segno zodiacale
corrispondente che nel mio caso è il
porco Chiediamo la moneta e lui ci dà la
pallina Questo è il martelletto non so
se porti fortuna che io lo posso aprire
anche con le mani Però tutti fanno con
le martelletto facciamo col martelletto
anche meno eh ragazzi
perfetto Eccola ragazzi la lotta è Tower
si vede da qua eh tipo gigantesca è
stata dall'altra parte si vede dalla
parte sud
[Musica]
e quindi ragazzi non so cosa sia
successo effettivamente ma se sta Piazza
è diventata una cosa un po'
folkloristica si chiama Seul Outdoor
library hanno fatto una libreria
all'aperto No ma che storia hanno messo
i libri tipo i sedere all'aperto e
leggere petizione per fare in Italia è
una cosa del genere ragazzi a Milano
voglio questa cosa a Milano a Gaeta se è
possibile grazie Allora prova
immedesimarmi nel popolo coreano un po'
come quella signora lì sediamo Qua tutto
ok ragazzi anche la signora è d'accordo
io potrei passare qua il resto della mia
vita ma se per caso non prendo l'aereo
che succede Mi vengono mica a pescare
qua molto ridere che è piuttosto casino
c'è un tipo testa qua che sta parlando e
ogni tanto si mette a suonare sono anche
dalla parte del culo della Statua Quindi
tutto perfetto
ah raga sta cosa è magica vedete che non
sta piovendo a Seul in tutta la corea ci
sono di irrigatori d'asfalto chiamiamoli
così catturano l'acqua piovana perché in
questi giorni ha piovuto abbastanza e la
riutilizzano per pulire la strada no
Strano perché non sta piovendo e c'è
tutto l'asfalto bagnato questa cosa è
assurda E quindi ragazzi come giornata
conclusiva Qua a Seul dovevo
assolutamente fare una cosa non potevo
esimermi da fare la Challenge numero uno
di Seul reputata proprio la cosa più
pericolosa para seoul che
pranzare qua italian spaghetti con una
scritta veramente poco pulita dal 1994
Quindi speriamo che questi premi
vogliono dire qualcosa Sono italiano
quindi posso giudicare No guarda Quante
stelle ha preso Proviamo subito ragazzi
Giusto per essere sicuri di servirvi al
meglio mi hanno messo di fianco alla
cassa posso farmi il conto da solo a
giudicare da quello che vedo Mmm non
giudichiamo prima di mangiare proviamo
prima a mangiare Innanzitutto mi portano
delle cose che secondo me non sono
commestibili ma apriamo il menù la prima
cosa che è noto subito è che l'insalata
mista di stagione nessuno gli ha mai
detto che mi stava scritto con la M
minuscola perché personaggio di Giorgio
ma in questo caso non lo è tutto il
resto mi sembra corretto il prezzo medio
è circa 13-14 euro neanche tanto non so
cosa prendere prendere gli spaghetti al
pomodoro normali visto che è il piatto
tipico di questo posto chiamato pomodoro
e questo è il mio meraviglioso piatto di
spaghetti al pomodoro vedo c'è la vista
non mi inganna ci sia qualcosa guardi
tipo un fungo
ma comunque Ragazzi Proviamo a vedere
quindi Ragazzi mi spiace ma non ho fatto
video del piatto perché se Guardate con
attenzione qua non si possono pubblicare
scene violente sensibili vi dica
Ah Thank you
non ho capito Cioè sono anche sporco
manco mangiare a 28 anni Vabbè comunque
sia ehm
Comunque sono abbastanza sicuro che
quello l'altra volta non ci fosse lì
cioè compaiono cose in questa città
penso che sia una boss Fight che si può
fare solo di giovedì e quindi ragazzi
anche questa stanza Purtroppo la
dobbiamo lasciare ci aspettano quindi
ragazzi altri nove giorni a Tokyo poi
dovrò tornare a casa Purtroppo ogni
tanto basso è a Milano e Ritardiamo la
cosa più possibile che dite Ed eccoci
quindi arrivati all'aeroporto di seoul
sono molto triste tanto che cacchio di
aeroporti Ma come mai è così figo sto
robot Non so guardate le impressioni che
posso darvi riguardo alla Corea le
persone sono gentili sono felici è tutto
figo cioè non so cosa dire Non c'è
niente che non va forse il cibo Ecco
quello Ah ecco un'altra cosa è tipo
magari anche la partita dei mondiali del
2002 anche i missili alle 6 del mattino
Raga ci pensano sono state proprio
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi sono nella mia stanza
d'albergo vi faccio questo video allo
specchio e che sono sfinito ma sono
tornato a Tokyo e siamo a shibuya Ma
l'ultimo video che questo secondo mega
viaggio che ho fatto uscirà appunto la
prossima settimana Spero che il viaggio
in Corea vi sia piaciuto e mi sono
divertito tantissimo Ci vediamo al
prossimo venerdì col prossimo video che
è l'ultimo del Giappone Dove visiterò
anche nuovi posti che non avete ancora
visto Quindi preparatevi e ciao
Come si potrebbe Chiudere questo video
in maniera in carica